So several years ago,
I was talking to a group of students and I was explaining to them
basically what's in 1st Corinthians 15.
I was explaining the fact that without the resurrection
Christianity would cease to exist.
And I had once described to me that it's almost if the resurrection was a tiny
little thread
connected to the fate of the world and if we were to cut that thread everything
would fall apart.
I was explaining this to my students and the looks on their faces were priceless.
You could tell that they didn't know anything that I was explaining to them.
It was all new news to them. They knew the resurrection.
They were good Christian kids.
They knew that and believed that Jesus had resurrected and they knew that it had
something to do or maybe everything to do with their salvation.
But they didn't realize that what if Jesus hadn't resurrected?
What if he had just stayed in the grave?
We always talked about Jesus was crucified for our sins,
but he was also resurrected.
So there's that second piece in the equation that's really super important.
Then I said to them,
did you know that there's historical evidence behind the resurrection?
Well, that was a whole nother look on their faces that I came and described.
It was fascinating,
but it was so encouraging to me because I knew that there was something to be taught
here and there was something that these students were going to gain from what I was
telling them.
It's likely that you're going to get some of those same looks as you start to talk
with some of your students about this because so many of students know that Jesus
existed.
I mean, let's face it. It's not a new thing that Jesus was a historical figure.
You're going to get a few people on the fringe that believe otherwise,
but all mainline history is Jesus existed.
He was crucified by the Romans. He was buried in a tomb and what?
It's reported that he rose three days after. Interesting.
But there's history behind it,
which is why we focus on Paul's comments in 1 Corinthians 15
to help students start to see the importance of the resurrection before we dive into
the historical reliability of the resurrection.
We want them to really get the whole picture of it along with the fact that even in
chapter 15,
Paul kind of gives a little bit of that historical account.
Like Jesus appeared to people.
He appeared to the 12 and he appeared to more than 500 people.
The way Paul says this is almost as if he's saying, hey, they're alive.
Go check it out. Go ask them.
If you don't believe me, it's no big deal.
So as your students are going through their intro experience,
we want them to start to think about historically documented and verified event that
happened before their lifetime.
So we want them to go into history.
We want them to see in a good place to do this is really in their history books.
How much of the Roman Empire do we know about?
How much of Alexander the Great do we know about?
How much of the Civil War do we know about?
How much of the historical events that happened long before us do we actually have
information on?
We want them to start to see it because as much as we look at Scripture,
because it is the Word of God and it's wholly inspired and it's awesome,
we also could take a step back and say, well,
what does this say from a historical perspective?
And what does it say about Jesus as a historical person?
What does it say about the resurrection as a historical event?
So we want students to start thinking of the resurrection just for a moment as a
historical event.
So that's what this exercise is really designed to do to connect them to the idea
that the resurrection is actually history.
Okay, so for your storyteller,
I would recommend going to a local college or a local Christian high school,
finding somebody that's a history professor or a history buff or somebody that
really just knows not just history,
but how to tell history well.
Find someone that knows how to tell the story of history.
And I say that because that's really what the Gospels are doing.
The Gospels are the account of Jesus.
We know this, but it's a story that's describing history.
So if you can get someone that can kind of do the same thing with another piece of
history,
you'll be able to help students start to make that connection and start to see the
Gospels as this historical narrative
that just sort of kind of wells up and culminates with the death and resurrection of
Christ.
It's a very cool picture. If you do it right, you can paint it really, really well.
We want to make sure that it's not a huge issue among students, but it is out there,
and they will run into this when they get to college,
that the resurrection was just a myth, right?
So, yeah, okay, Jesus died,
and it's a myth that the church made up that he resurrected.
And it's important that we kind of help students see that that's not historically
accurate.
And we'll get into more of why that is as we move forward the next couple of weeks,
but it's important to kind of help students see that that is something that they're
going to hear
as they go into college and beyond.
Okay,
so students are going to be able to see at the end of this that the resurrection is
actually historical.
Now,
does that mean that we can say that this is a for-sure thing and that it's absolute?
Well, I would say, yeah, of course it is, but that's a bit different.
But can we prove that Jesus resurrected?
Well, not beyond a shadow of a doubt, of course not.
But we can't do that with anything in history, right?
We can't prove too many things in history beyond shadow of a doubt because we
weren't there.
But how history is done and what you'll see even the storyteller from the historian
is that the one with the best evidence is the one who gets to say what happened.
So the question is, is do we have the best possible evidence for the resurrection?
So there's a couple of things that I want to make sure you can explore this deeper.
You can get into a little bit more. You can present to your students.
You can get into discussions about this within your small group time.
If your students want to go a little bit deeper,
there's some really cool things you can do.
So the resurrection as history.
Now, when we think of history, most people think of, well, it's the Bible, right?
So the number one place that we all look is, well, the Bible.
Well, the Bible could be viewed as a history book.
That's the word of God.
We don't want to make a textbook, but there's history in it.
Okay, that's great.
So there's some evidence there.
So we have one piece of evidence in the Bible.
But what do people say?
Well, that's the Bible and you can't believe everything the Bible says.
Well, we'll get into that later.
Actually, we can, but we'll get into that later.
But what else then, right?
Are there other things?
Well, what about outside of the Bible?
Are there things outside of the Bible that give us clues that Jesus resurrected?
There is, right?
There are Jewish historians.
There are Roman historians that recorded events about the resurrection,
that at least the disciples of the early years thought that Jesus resurrected
and recorded that they're reporting that Jesus resurrected.
So that's important.
There are early Christian writings like the Didache and letters from a church
father named Clement that talk about the resurrection.
These aren't in the Bible.
They're good Christian writings, the stuff that we still kind of use and study
in the world of scholarship to figure out what's going on historically.
But that's awesome.
Okay.
And you've got even now skeptics, people that aren't Christians,
are saying that Jesus was reported as resurrected.
Now, this kind of raises the question.
All right.
Well, if all of these areas say that Jesus resurrected
or at least give us clues to know that people believe that he did,
that's pretty good.
Well, maybe there's other explanations.
Maybe there's other things that are going on.
Well, every other explanation given has to provide more evidence,
better evidence than the hypothesis, if you will, that he resurrected.
And when you do that without going into all the details,
when you do that, they all fall short.
The one that says he just sort of fainted and that he did wasn't really dead.
So therefore, you didn't have to worry about it.
There's ones that he was buried.
He wasn't actually buried in the tomb.
He was buried in a shallow grave and some birds and wild dogs end up eating his
body.
There's some people that say, you know, they just grabbed a body
and pretended it was Jesus and it really wasn't.
And there's all kinds of different theories,
none of which have the same amount of evidence as the resurrection.
So this is exactly why we wanted to connect it with history.
Because when we look at other historical events and how much evidence there are for
those,
we have just as much or more for the resurrection as pretty much most other
historical events,
especially historical events that happened around the same time.
And we'll see that from when we talk about Scripture specifically.
So help your students see that this was a historical event,
that there's evidence as a historical event.
But just like last week, I would do the same thing that you did last week.
I'd go into your small groups and I would ask them,
number one,
are you convinced that it's at least possible the evidence points to Jesus
resurrecting?
And number two, if you are convinced, what does that mean?
We talked in the very beginning about the importance of the resurrection, right?
If the resurrection is out there, all of Christianity falls down.
So if you're convinced in the resurrection, what does that now mean for your life?
And what needs to change?
What needs to be furthered?
How does your spiritual walk need to go even further than maybe it is now?
What does that mean for you?
What does that mean for how you talk to other people about the resurrection in Jesus
and who he is and what the crucifixion resurrection actually means
and what salvation is all about?
Ask students to sort of not just do they believe this stuff,
but have them dig into, okay, now what?
What does all this mean?
What do I do with all this information?
And if they're not convinced and they're still kind of going, I'm not sure.
That's okay.
But now is the time where you can start digging a little bit into,
okay, well, what questions do you continue to have?
What roadblocks are there that I can help knock down?
What do I need to do to help bring you along a little bit,
maybe better to help you understand these things a little bit deeper?
Is it a misunderstanding?
Is I'm just not getting something?
Or is it something bigger?
Now is the time that you might start to see some roadblocks and some students'
lives,
some walls they might put up.
They might want to believe this stuff.
They might really like love the idea,
but they might still hold back.
And as you walk alongside these students,
you're going to need to start figuring out why that is
and what's going on and start to, that's why we talked to the very beginning,
the importance of building relationships
because now it's going to start to really matter.
If it hasn't mattered before, now it's really going to get there
because there's going to be some major changes going on in your students' lives.